hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm so they're gonna be
going over the win over variation in the
French defense French being one of the
more popular chess openings with E for e
6 and then d4 d5 striking the center of
the board white usually responds with
Knight c3 this is the main line
defending this pawn and the stern of the
board on e4 and Bishop to b4 this is the
winner or variation we're gonna go over
all the main lines that you will see II
five is pretty common here if they want
to exchange with the exchange variation
they can do that pawn a3 just attacking
the bishop as well Knights to e2 one
option Bishop to d3 defending the pawn
that's gonna be important or you could
just see Bishop to d2 they know that the
Knights being pinned down right now and
so maybe they want to defend with their
bishop all of those moves are gonna be
better than something like Knight to f3
because this knight on c3 s we talked
about defending the pawn but really
that's all that's hanging between the
pend taking here and since this Knights
being pinned down to the King by this
bishop here it needs an extra defender
because I have to remove like Knight to
f3
then the pawn can simply take here on e4
this is gonna be extremely bad for white
Blacks gonna be up in material same
thing with a normal Bishop to e2 move
pawn can just take right here the night
can't recapture it's being pinned down
there though is one caveat that's why
we're gonna go over that and that's
Knight to e2 that is a variation where
yes the pawns should be taking here but
White's able to get that material back
so we are gonna start with the main line
and that is white continuing with pawn
to e5 after E 5 black is going to play
c5 just trying to strike this pawn
structure in at the center of the board
for white and white has a few options as
far as how they want to respond the main
line is going to be pawn to a3 and many
places will say that the main line for
black would continue with Bishop takes
on c3 and then the pawns going to
recapture and then maybe Knight to e7
this is
not the preferred way that I like to
play I think it's not as easy to play
from blacks perspective none I think you
have a lot more fighting chances if you
choose a different move and that is
after pawn to a3 actually to take the
pawn here on d4 and the reason for that
is breaking up this pawn center for
white is crucial when you are attacking
with the French defense so let's look at
some of the options that they have here
one of them would be to take the bishop
here on b4 that's gonna be completely
fun go ahead and take with your pawn if
they want to recapture here then usually
Queen to c7 this is attacking both the
pawn here on e5 also the pawn right here
they could play Knight to f3 defending
this pawn right here you could say
Knight c7 or knight c6 here attacking
the pawn you definitely have some
options if they want to bring their
Bishop down b5 pinning down our knight
that's completely ok we could bring our
Bishop to b7 if they want to exchange
that's completely ok with us this is a
very good setup for black good pawn
structure here you can look at the pond
they're not that great for white all of
a sudden White has a very good game in
the French defense another move instead
of the pond taking on a before you could
see the Queen get involved so pawn takes
and then Queen to g4 many players when
they face off against the French defense
they are prepared to bring their Queen
down here usually the Queen doesn't come
down get this aggressive to g4 because
black usually has their knight on f6
it's a very common move for black to
play but you can see that's not going to
be the case in the French because
usually the French ends up with the pawn
here on e5 and so if the Knights gonna
be moving it's more coming to 7 so
there's opportunity for the Queen to
attack this King side of the board but
the Queen can't take right away the
pawns gonna recapture for black here if
it were to come down that would be a
disaster the pawn takes here that's a
discovered attack now with the bishop
attacking
King here so have to defend that pawn
takes the bishop and then Queen on a one
after the capture so that's not going to
be a good plan for White's another
option that wife has and one of the
reasons I like to take with the pawn
instead of the bishop is if they take
with their queen that's going to be
completely okay as well continue to take
with the pawn here they could recapture
with their queen queen comes up here to
c7 now of a sudden you look at this very
good pawn structure for black here this
pawns hanging out here it's an isolated
pawn right now and then from White's
perspective he has kind of a pawn
hanging out here isolated pawn and from
blacks perspective he can develop like
normal and have a very good game from
here so that's what happens if they play
that pawn to a3 early on another
alternative you may see is Bishop d2
people do not like having their pieces
being pinned down so just bring your
bishop here since yeah if you want to
take I will recapture blacks gonna play
Knight to e7 this is really the only
place you're gonna be bringing your
Knights can't come to f6 you can really
see that and this really can get your
knight involved into the game how you
want it to this is a great outpost here
on f5 is not really gonna be kicking
this off with his pawns who's not
playing pawn g4 probably so this is a
great square where it eventually lead to
the knight getting involved into the
game now they have a couple options if
they want to play Knight to f3 trying to
defend the center of the board I would
still go ahead and take capturing these
pawns in this urn the board is just so
crucial to a solid French attack ah I
think that's definitely the way to go
now if they want to retake with or
Knight I think this is completely fine
I'd still take blacks position in this
setup now instead of Knight to f3 maybe
now they play pawn to e3 I feel like
it's always good to know what to do if
you see that common moves like a three
here I'd go ahead and capture if they
want to recapture I play knight c6 and
the reason for that yes you are giving
up a pawn in material but the reason you
can do that is because the next move and
it's very crucial if you miss it
you're not gonna have as great of a game
and that's pawn to d4 and that's
attacking the bishop so after the bishop
moves because it's being defended by
both the Knights and the Queen right
here
then you have a couple options you could
one go ahead and take the night here on
e5 and they have no central pawns that's
an option or you could play Queen d5 is
what I really like very aggressive
you're now attacking both of the pawns
you have multiple options now you can
play Knight to e5 so black has a much
more aggressive stance we're usually in
the French defense most people think of
white having this strong attack all
their pawns lining up on the Kings side
and they just start forcing a strong
attack on the King side no no we're
gonna squash that with the way we're
going to attack with the French defense
now said the bishop coming to be -
another option that you could see from
white is just go ahead and take the pawn
here on c5 I think that's completely
fine for Black Knight to e7 is going to
be the move and there's just no real
good way for them to hold on to this
pawn right here because you can always
just come back and capture it and you
still have two central pawns they do not
if they want to try to hold on to it
with Queen d4 which they probably
wouldn't but then you just can play
knight c6 forcing the Queen back you're
gonna eventually take the material if
they try to hold on to it with their
bishop
well now you activate your knight Knight
to f5 attacking the bishop if they want
to try to come here d4 one yes you could
go ahead and take it but you could also
just play Queen to a5 this is
double-barreling here on the pin and
also another attacker on the c5 square
White's just not gonna be hold being
able to hold on to that material so
those are the main variations that
you'll see after they play that e five
move now we come back to the initial
setup and the winner were a variation
they don't have to play e5 and so
another option that you would see is the
exchange variation doesn't happen all
that often
but sometimes players don't like playing
the French and cells
I'll just go ahead and exchange the
material in the standard board go ahead
and take with your pawn right here
nothing too crazy is gonna happen in
this you could see Knight to f3
defending the pawn right here you're
just gonna continue with normal Knight
to c6 there defending your attacking
maybe Bishop down here to d3 Knight to
f6 which is not something you commonly
are doing in the French defense but
since the pawns not here on e5 you can
easily come Knight f6 casts on the King
side both sides are gonna be completely
fun if instead you see something like
Bishop coming down to b5 sure knight c6
if they want to capture that's fine you
now have the bishop pair they don't yes
you do have double pawns here on the C
file but it's very easy for you later on
to play something like c5 you can easily
get rid of the double pods usually
they're not going to do this but some
options that you'll see in the game if
you come across the exchange variation
now instead of the exchange you could
see just pawn a3 right away attacking
the bishop this is not nearly as good
for white so if you're looking at
different moves or even if your playing
is white just know that II five
definitely stronger that's why it's more
in the mainline but some people they
they like to say if you're pinning down
my piece I want to attack that right
away go ahead and take right here on c3
because after they take you can go ahead
and take with your pawn right here on e4
cuz that is the threat that they have
now we talked about this in an earlier
raishin they still have queen g4 and I
would recommend in this spot to go ahead
and play Knight to f6 yes if they want
to go ahead and take material right here
on g7 that's just something you're gonna
have to learn to play against because
you can chase them around rook to g8
both the pawns are defended one by the
knight one by the King here and this
rooks also also defended by the knight
so you're gonna chase the Queen around
right here and then eventually you can
play Queen g6 you do have an active
board state eventually if you wanted to
castle on the Queen
side you could even do that but this is
a position you may see yourself in
doesn't happen all that often sometimes
they'll just give you that pawn on e4
recognize they made a huge mistake
try to do something else you can see
they can't come to f3 make some further
mistakes you can develop your board
state as normal and have a pretty easy
game if they do they get their queen
involved into the game just be prepared
to play on this board setup the next
variation is Knight to e2 and we've
already talked about blacks threat right
away is taking on e4 and if you don't
have a way to defend this because the
knight can't capture it's being pinned
down right now you're up a pawn and
material but this is the one exception
because they're going to be able to get
that material back because after a three
there's no way to hold on
meaning if you try to bring your bishop
back with people that's gonna be out of
the way then they could just take this
pawn right here you no longer pin
pinning down at that night if you decide
ok a3 and then you want to go ahead and
capture the material which is what you
should be doing then Knight to c3 and
now you are going to lose this pawn and
I would not recommend trying to hold on
to it with something like f5 it just
really messes up your pawn structure
right here it's just not worth it so if
they do play this I would instead play
c6 this does attack their pawn right now
you have both your queen and your knight
attacking that so you could see III and
then Knight to f6 you can see that adds
another layer of protection right now
and then maybe Bishop down to f6 trying
to pin down the material you can see
this is a mistake because then the Queen
can just come up and take this material
right here now this is important because
if we come back to the very beginning of
this spot I initially said if they take
don't play Knight to f5 now some people
maybe look at this say why not play
Knight to f6 this does defend this
material the reason is
bishop down to g5 the knight has the
same problem that this knight on c3 has
it's pinned down it cannot defend this
material and there's no way to really
attack any material here from blacks
perspective that's very different than
if you start with c3 as I'm recommending
or c6 skews me attacking this pawn now
if they wanted to thin it they defend
with their Bishop you bring your night
out here to f6 and if they want to come
down and pin the material well now you
have this night here on c6 the attacking
material not saying they will come down
and pin the material but it's always
important to know what piece to move in
the correct order because now you've put
them in a really tricky spots while
they're trying to get this material back
they really can't at least with these
move variations because you have the
upper hand you have both of your Knights
that are active in the game so that's
what happens if they play Knight to g2
go ahead and take with your pawn right
here but just be prepared to give that
material back next variation we're gonna
look at is Bishop to d3 knowing that the
threat is the pon taking on e4 you may
see the bishop come and defend that pawn
I would still capture gobbling up
material in the center of the board is
the key to success in the French defense
in my opinion now the bishop could take
that's completely fine Knight to f6 here
because the pawn is not going to be on
e5 attacking the bishop on e4 depending
on where it goes a couple options Bishop
to f3 that's fine
you have three variations on how you
could play I'll give you my
recommendation but c5 if you're one of
those people that likes to exchange
Queens and then play that game not my
cup of tea but a lot of people like to
play that if you want to play more of a
safe route castle on the King side you
have that option as well I usually just
like to get more material involved into
the game Knight to c6 here if they want
to take right here yes you do have
double pawns here on the C file but like
we talked about before playing pawn to
c5 you can easily get those back and now
you do have a bishop
hair and you can easily open up this
board states that's usually what I'm
opting for if we come back if they don't
play knight or Bishop to f3 they could
play Bishop to g5 pinning down that
night that's also an option Knight to d7
now is a very good move you could castle
on the Kings side although this is gonna
be a very good game from black you can
see so many variations depending on
where black goes you have a really
strong setup and they do not control the
center of the board which they like to
do in the French defense the last
variation we're going to look at instead
of the bishop coming to d3 is Bishop d2
you pin down a piece they like to defend
it with their Bishop they don't want to
have double pawns which makes perfect
sense in this case this is not a very
good move from white this is falling
under that category of yeah let's go
ahead and take that pawn right here and
the reason this is bad is okay now the
Knights not pinned down if they want to
take that's fine but the Queen taking on
d4 is just detrimental to them this is
attacking so many different things out
there if they want to come back Knight
to c3
that's fine Knight to f6 you can
continue your development as normal now
the better move for them after you take
this pawn is to play Knight to e2 but
that's a really tough move for them to
find after that move then Knight to f6
another piece attacking or defending the
square here on e4 maybe now they attack
you exchange a material right here and
then knight c6 this is you have much
better active pieces in the game all in
all I would definitely be taking black
in this position so this is the winner
where variation one of the more common
variations you'll run up against in the
French defense because you're just going
against the main lines that white is
playing so if you're new to the French
defense or you're curious from White's
perspective what are some of the lines
that you could see hopefully this was a
good introduction to the winnower and
you have much more confidence going into
the French defense because it is a very
very sound defense it gives you a very
good
tacking options if you are black thanks
again for watching the video I'll see
you guys in the next one I'm gonna have
a lot more variations of the French
defense coming out so make sure you
check out the chess website comm for
more updates of the French defense